I'm John Ball this is my beautiful wife
when we live in San Antonio Texas and in
2015
I took a two thousand six hundred and
eighty three mile walk across the United
States beginning in San Diego California
and I finished my walk in Daytona Beach
Florida
[Music]
f/16 his buddies out there somewhere
brother wen and I got married very young
and after graduated from college I had
never been in an airplane never flown an
airplane I've never even bought a ticket
and ridden on an airplane and so I went
down to the recruiters office in our
hometown of Paris Texas and applied to
go to Air Force pilot training when Winn
was very supportive of that and off we
went to the Air Force 26 years later I
retired as a colonel having been a pilot
for most of that time including a
two-year stint as Air Force two pilot
for Vice President Gore and Vice
President Cheney
throughout my Air Force career I'd
always been an avid exerciser I'd go out
jogging 6 8 10 miles a day but towards
the end of my career I was approaching
50 years old my knees started hurting
pretty bad I went to the doctor the
doctor said you really need to lay off
the running for a while so I started
walking very the very next day I started
walking for exercise and I never stopped
walking so I was just honestly out
walking one day and it just crossed my
mind I wonder what it would be like to
walk a long distance
specifically I immediately came to my
mind what would it be like to walk all
the way across the country after I
retired from the Air Force I went to
work here in San Antonio with a
government contractor and at that point
when and I were able to live off of my
Air Force pension but we wanted to
rebuild our retirement home and here in
San Antonio with the exception of the
savings that we did we put everything
else towards paying off our retirement
home
after I retired I immediately started on
this walk the walk ended up being 2686
miles and 170 days from March 1st to
August 17th
well they're a couple couple of things
that I had to consider number one I had
to be in good enough health to be able
to walk that kind of distance it's
pretty grueling walking 270 days without
a lot of rest
the other thing is economically I had to
be able to do that and that all tied
into being debt-free we cash flowed the
entire trip and the purpose of the trip
was to create an endowed scholarship at
my alma mater Texas A&M and because I
had prepared financially to be able to
go on the walk at my own cost all the
donations that came in went straight to
the scholarship there's a tradition at
Texas A&M about the Aggie ring we've had
the same graduation ring for over a
hundred years and so really it's a it's
your tradition and it's a it's an honor
that all Aggies have to wear their Aggie
ring but not everybody can afford their
Aggie ring when it's time for them to to
get it 350 very generous people gave
over $27,000 to establish the walking
Aggie and doubt ring scholarship so that
each year one male student our two
female students receive their a green as
a result of the scholarship and my
completion of the coast-to-coast walk
I got more than my share of input from
people telling me that it was dangerous
that there are a lot of mean people out
there and that it was just generally a
bad idea to to go walking on my own
without any help or support for six
months I will tell you that that is the
one thing that I learned throughout this
walk was how kind people are in six
months I never had one single incident
where I felt threatened in any way by
anyone I walked into gas stations I
walked into cafes I was greeted on the
shoulder of the road with people
offering me rides and water and food the
the best experience out of the whole
trip was just how kind people were to me
there was a relief because as the family
we were very worried about his safety
and he just had a great experience
I had a very detailed plan for the walk
I knew where I was supposed to be every
day with that in mind we booked the
Disney cruise that left the afternoon of
August the 17th so I knew before I ever
started on March 1st in San Diego that I
had to be in Daytona Beach Florida on
August 17th or that cruise ship was
gonna leave without us
the whole family flew up to San Diego to
see mom and really comes back because we
were all together and about to go to
Disneyland and here he was all by
herself can walk away but anyway we
could talk every day just very seldom
did we not speak every day so we're
trying to kept up with Dean and knew
that he was okay it just all worked out
good and then we all went including my
mom on the other end and took a Disney
cruise so he better finish on time dead
free we were millionaires by then and
that just that just freed us up to be
able to really go out and live life the
way we had planned for a long time you
know we go to Europe and tulle around
Europe with our backpacks for weeks at a
time we have a goal we motorcycle with a
little trailer we pull over it behind it
we just got back from a trip to Canada
and then in April we're going to visit
Eastern Europe so we really like to
travel and being debt-free has enabled
us to do that and that was something we
always hopefully to do and and now we're
living in
being debt-free before I started this
walk it really enabled me to be able to
pull this off we saved our entire Air
Force career and we saved and we're able
to pay off our house and become
debt-free the month that I've started on
the walk and it really it really just
lived out the philosophy that if you
live like no one else you can live and
give like no one else
[Music]
[Music]